les valaisannes prix nobel de la paix le
monde a reconnu la lutte et les idéaux
de solidarité il n'y a qu'une seule voie
celle du dialogue s'exclame le lauréat a
dance pas de consensus africain pour
résoudre le problème du tchad après le
sommet de vittel invités de ce journal
le président du tchad hissène habré
conseil des ministres pour lutter contre
l'alcoolisme au volant des modifications
du code de la route et du code des
débits de boissons sont envisagées la
sphère des irlandais de vincennes
la cour d'appel de paris annule toute la
procédure visant les trois irlandais
présenté il ya un an comme de dangereux
terroristes
ça y est ça y est oui oui c'est vrai qu'
non non non je ne crois pas si ça y est
je n'y crois pas je te jure parole
d'honneur c'était la dernière nouvelle à
la radio
ils ont dit que c'était lech walesa qui
a obtenu le prix nobel
il faut le croire je t'assure ce n'est
pas une blague je suivre ce c'est une
grande chose dit mais je ne crois pas
monsieur bonsoir il y croyait si peu
qu'il était parti tranquillement ce
matin à la pêche
pourtant son nom comme l'an dernier
figurait parmi les candidats les mieux
placés pour recevoir le prix nobel de la
paix est ce matin à oslo le comité nobel
a décidé de couronner les valises à pour
sa contribution à assurer le droit des
travailleurs au prix de sacrifices
personnels considérable le communiqué
poursuit les activités de valaisans ont
été caractérisées par la détermination à
résoudre les problèmes de son pays
son recours à la violence par la
négociation et la coopération
walesa est un interprète du désir de
paix et de liberté qui en dépit de
convictions diverses demeure invaincu
parmi tous les peuples du monde
fin de citation cette explication du
comité nobel
les polonais
ne la connaissent toujours pas mais la
nouvelle leur suffit même si les organes
d'information officielle manifestement
embarrassés ne l'ont annoncé que tard
dans l'après-midi les polonaises jubile
philippe harrouard le journal polonais
de ce soir comment s'est il y à peine
une demi-heure
la nouvelle a été annoncé sèchement et
brièvement en troisième position
cinq minutes après le début du journal
la présentatrice que vous voyez ici a
insisté sur le fait que le prix nobel
les prix nobel sont toujours
pratiquement politique et donc
contestable
elle a donné l'exemple de monsieur
béguines l'embarras des autorités
polonaises a donc été marquée par le peu
d'empressement des médias a annoncé la
nouvelle aujourd'hui la radio nationale
a fait état du prix nobel de lech walesa
vers 16 heures
c'est à dire six heures après la non
officiel d'oslo reprise immédiatement
par les radios occidental dans les
ministères et dans les bureaux de presse
du gouvernement polonais aucun
responsable n'était accessible pour
commenter l'information
dans son audience générale aujourd'hui
au vatican le pape jean paul ii n'a pas
évoqué l'événement
mais dans son entourage qui est
largement polonais tout le monde jubile
dit on ce soir au bar au vatican en
occident des chefs d'état aux syndicats
c'est la satisfaction générale et à
l'est c'est le silence silence officiel
qui masquent à peine une mise en cause
politique du choix du comité nobel en
ligne de moscou le correspondant de la
ftb magog un contre-révolutionnaire et
on sait le mépris mais le dire mais
votre course a de quoi être mécontents
parce que c'est la troisième fois
qu'arrive ce que le kremlin a fait une
provocation prix nobel de la paix en
prix nobel de la littérature en 1970
mais pour le kremlin ce mec va les
appeler plus grave car il ya eu ces
d'énormes dangers de contagion de
solidarité dans la partie basse de
l'union soviétique dans une certaine
mesure quand l'ensemble du clan
communiqué
ce prix est une grande chose pour moi et
pour notre mouvement nous pouvons encore
une fois prouvé qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
voie celle du dialogue
ce commentaire de vale a lui même
lorsqu'on lui a appris la nouvelle cet
après midi là dedans ce qui montre bien
que pour les partisans de solidarité en
pologne
ce prix nobel au delà de l'homme qu'il
couronne honore aussi une cause une
cause toute entière symbolisée par ce
visage trois images de symboles pour
l'homme devenu le symbole de tout un
peuple
d'abord lech walesa chez lui à dents
parmi les siens les ouvriers du chantier
naval avec son gros stylo il signe les
fameux accords de danse rêve d'une
liberté syndicale vite oublié
deuxième image lech walesa avec un autre
de ses concitoyens le plus illustre
valaisanne est allé à rome le pape s'est
rendu en pologne
dernière image c'était il ya une semaine
au cours d'un match de football à gdansk
la vedette n'est pas sur le terrain
c'est encore une fois lech walesa
attaqué par le pouvoir mais soutenu par
tous les siens
il est incontestable que ce prix nobel
décerné à lech walesa confortera l'homme
et son action il est incontestable
également que cette distinction
encouragera tous ceux et ils sont
nombreux autour de lui à poursuivre leur
combat
il est incontestable enfin que ce nobel
est un défi origines de varsovie et au
kremlin les autorités polonaises ont
voulu faire de lech walesa un citoyen
ordinaire mais les occidentaux en font
aujourd'hui un citoyen extraordinaire
cependant tout le problème est de savoir
si ce geste n'a pas finalement qu'une
portée purement symbolique
un peu comme si les occidentaux ne
pouvaient être tribus et qu'une médaille
à celui qui symbolise les aspirations de
liberté de tout un peuple en effet
rappelez vous un autre homme en 1975
avait eu le prix nobel de la paix tout
comme vale zahil défendez les droits de
l'homme dans les pays communistes
cet homme c'est le soviétique andreï
sakharov
aujourd'hui sakharov est en train de
mourir en exil à gorki dans une
indifférence presque totale et le
problème maintenant est de savoir si les
valises à pourra se rendre à oslo
recevoir son prix et vient d'annoncer
qu'il demandera un parent d'aller
chercher l'argent du prix soit un
million et demi de francs il a
l'intention de donner l'argent l église
catholique de son pays
la dimension politique de ce prix nobel
s'impose bien sûr au régime de vars se
vit comme au kremlin
il s'impose aussi dans les pays
européens où les partis communistes et
les syndicats qui leur sont proches ne
masquent pas leur embarras ainsi à rome
le cet inter général du parti communiste
français georges marchais qui concluait
cette après midi une visite de deux
jours à son homologue italien enrico
berlinguer georges marchais a réagi avec
quelques agacements aux questions des
victoires en berne les commentaires que
vous ferez sur le prix nobel
c'est votre affaire et moi sur cette
question du prix nobel j'ai mon opinion
mais assez bonnes opinions personnelles
j'osais et prix nobel si on fait les six
ont fait les groupes en ce qui me
concerne si je fais des commentaires sur
si on prend dix quinze ans en arrière on
pourrait dire beaucoup de choses je ça
n'appelle pas de ma part un commentaire
tout ce qui me concerne j'apprenne la
nouvelle d'un en ce moment et à gauche y
réfléchir mais je pense que demain on va
augmenter c'est vers cette nouvelle
aussi à paris à l'assemblée nationale au
cours des questions d'actualité cet
après midi le premier ministre pierre
mauroy et le président du groupe udf
jean claude gaudin ont salué l'un et
l'autre la récompense de valises à aux
applaudissements du parti socialiste et
des partis de l'opposition le parti
communiste est resté impassible serait
heureux que le président plaide
l'assemblée nationale dans son ensemble
s'associer à cet hommage
j'ai pris effectivement que les
chevalets da re les avait été distingué
pour le prix nobel et par le prix nobel
et je veux cette occasion rendre hommage
à lech walesa vous avez comment sur les
bancs de la majorité
comment au gouvernement nous l'avons
reçue
comment le combat qu'il mène contre
l'arbitraire est un combat digne et un
combat nord mais vous permettre
vous me permettrez de préciser mais vous
permettrez je vous en prie douter la
suite
mais vous me permettrez de préciser que
lorsque nous rendons hommage à lech
walesa nous rendons compte un homme qui
lutte pour la liberté d'une façon
presque universel et nous voulons y voir
le symbole de tout ce qui dans le monde
lutte contre les dictatures et contre
l'arbitraire m6
le pape jean paul ii a envoyé un
télégramme de félicitations à les
valises à je la prends à l'instant
télégramme où jean paul ii insiste sur
la récompense ainsi octroyé au dialogue
sincère et à la volonté de coopération
entre tous dans notre dernier journal à
23h10 un débat sur la portée du prix
nobel de la paix 83 opposera josé de
brouckère directeur de la vie à alain
lautier de libération vivent ainsi dans
cet après midi à l'assemblée à propos de
l'enseignement privé
l'opposition a quitté l'hémicycle au
moment où le ministre de l'éducation
nationale alain savary s'apprêtait à
répondre à une question du rpr claude
labbé que ce lui avait adressée au
premier ministre sur le fond du problème
rien de nouveau sinon la confirmation de
négociations qui vont être proposées par
le ministre aux responsables de
l'enseignement privé
ordre du jour chargé pour le conseil des
ministres de ce matin
la stratégie industrielle de la france
la modernisation de cette industrie par
les nouvelles technologies
autrement dit productique et un projet
de loi qui vise à remédier un fléau
national l'alcoolisme au volant
certaines dispositions du code de la
route et du code des débits de boisson
vont sans doute être modifié lucie
semoule
première mesure la conduite en état
d'ivresse constituera désormais un délit
à partir d'un taux de 0,2 loïc g
d'alcool dans le sang
ce taux était jusqu'à présent de 1,2
grave
deuxième mesure le dispositif de
contrôle sera améliorée l'éthylomètre
succède maintenant à l'alcootest cet
appareil permettra de mesurer avec
précision le taux d'alcool contenue dans
l'haleine sans avoir besoin de faire une
prise de sang
enfin ce projet prévoit une
harmonisation du code des débits de
boisson et du code de la route
ceci afin d' aggraver les sanctions
prévues contre les conducteurs en état
d'ivresse
sur la route meurent chaque année plus
de 12000 personnes près de la moitié
d'entre elles au moins sont tués par
l'alcool
les contrôles lors de conduite en état
d'ivresse lequel malheureusement quand
ils ont lieu c'est toujours après
l'accident
actuellement environ 40% des
responsables d'accidents mortels ont une
alcoolémie qui dépasse 0 g 80 par lille
ça représente environ 5000 morts par an
en france
mais la répartition est très différent
d'une répartition homogène c'est que il
ya cinq fois plus d'hommes que de femmes
toutes proportions gardées dans ses
responsables on sait aussi qu'il ya très
peu de jeunes ou dessous de 16 ans peut
aussi de gens âgés passer 50 55 ans
c'est donc une période moyenne de la vie
qui est en cause et puis on sait aussi
qu'il ya trop de variations régionales
qui recoupe en gros la carte de la
cirrhose du foie et de la consommation
excessive d'alcool le passage de 1 g 20
à 0 g 8 pour la limite du délit est
importante parce qu'on est déjà dans une
zone où le risque est très augmenté car
il faut bien voir que le risque de
provoquer un accident lié à l'alcool
n'est pas constant de zéro g 80 jusqu'à
3 ou 4 g à 0 g 50 on a à peu près deux
fois le risque de ceux qui ont une
alcoolémie nul mais quand on arrive dans
la zone zéro g 81 g 20 c'est déjà plus
de dix fois le risque de base
demant ce chiffre le facteur de risque
qui sait bondir les assureurs qui ont
déjà du mal avec les bons conducteurs
ils ont décidé de pénaliser par l'argent
les conducteurs alcoolique après un
accident dû à l'alcool
leur prime sera augmenté de 150% il faut
du reste à savoir que cet arrêté prévoit
d'autres situations où les
automobilistes les mauvais conducteurs
risquent de voir leurs primes
d'assurance grimper il s'agira par
exemple des conducteurs dont le permis
de conduire a été annulé ou résiliés
augmentations de primes possible entre
50 et 200 % selon la gravité de la cause
commune de la faute commise troisième
situation le délit de fuite le chauffard
qui provoque un accident et prend la
fuite pour avoir sa prime augmenter le
son pour cent à toutes ces constatations
il faut ajouter le coût de l'alcoolisme
pour la société un coût médical aussi
bien que social il se chiffre en
dizaines de milliards
certains avancent même le chiffre d'une
centaine devant lé conseil des ministres
de ce matin le président mitterrand a
évoqué le sommet franco africain qui
s'est terminée hier soir à vittel le
chef de l'état a souligné qu'il n'était
pas dans la tradition de ce genre de
sommets de donner lieu à une décision
mais que ces résultats constituent est
une étape dans la solution du problème
tchadien
jusqu'ici le président du tchad hissène
habré s'est refusé à tout commentaire
merci donc d'être en direct avec nous
monsieur le président de votre ambassade
à paris
alors pour vous sauver de vittel est ce
que ça a été du temps perdu
ou est ce que un pas a été franchi vers
une solution du problème de votre pays
bien la conférence
le sommet de vittel qui s'est ténu
tout récemment a regroupé comme le veut
la tradition nombreux chefs d'état
d'afrique et les chefs de l'état
français le président françois
mitterrand
je dois dire que ce sommet s'est tenu
dans un cadre idéal et l'hospitalité le
confort entourant les chefs d'état de
france et d'afrique ont pu discuter
prendre des contacts et échanger leurs
points de vue est ce qu'il ya eu des
résultats des résultats il faut pas
attendre de cette conférence des
résultats miracle d'ailleurs selon les
traditions
cette rencontre permet aux uns et aux
autres de faire progresser certains
sujets importants et vous savez que
cette année la question du tchad a eu
l'honneur de figurer parmi les sujets
les plus importants traités à vittel on
a dit monsieur le président comme qui
est prêt à négocier négocier avec qui
voyez vous nous avons eu toujours par
rapport au drame du peuple italien une
position claire et constante
nous avons toujours admis qu'il faut
explorer rechercher toutes les voies
menant à la paix et parmi ceux voix il y
à la voix pacifique
vous aurez pardon vous êtes prêts à
parler avec monsieur ronnie wood et nous
sommes prêts et nous l'avons toujours
été nous le sommes nous le serons nous
sommes prêts à discuter avec tous les
canadiens de l'opposition que ça soit
goukouni que ça soit les autres
est ce que ça veut dire que vous
reconnaissez monsieur goukouni oueddei
une certaine représentativité
le cadre a connu un drame qui a 12
et pratiquement 17 ans et nous entrons
dans la 18ème année nous voulons pour
notre peuple et pour notre pays la paix
la stabilité et le respect de son
intégrité territoriale
le sa souveraineté que ça soit beaucoup
ni encore une fois que ce soit les
autres canadiens tous sens bien sont les
bienvenus nos portes sont ouvertes et
d'ailleurs dans le passé nous avons fait
des efforts dans ce sens nous le faisons
aujourd'hui nous le ferons demain et à
vittel dieu merci les chefs d'état
africains qui étaient présents ont tous
accepté d'apporter leur concours pour
voir le 4 enfin retrouvé la paix et la
quiétude
monsieur le président est ce que vous
seriez prêt à organiser au tchad des
élections pour que l'on sache enfin ce
que les tchadiens eux-mêmes pense de
cette rivalité qui se perpétue entre
vous même et monsieur goukouni ne
parlons pas de rivalité entre et
moi-même et monsieur gauck unis je pense
qu'il est important pour l'opinion en
particulier pour le peuple français de
savoir que le problème le plus important
au tchad
c'est l'occupation de ce pays par un
autre pays à savoir la libye qui occupe
actuellement la moitié du cade plus de
500 mille kilomètres carrés du problème
du cadre c'est d'abord ce problème en ce
qui concerne les querelles de personnes
les questions secondaires
ce sont là des problèmes qui peuvent
être réglés facilement par conséquent
nous sommes de ce point de vue encore
une fois disposé à entamer le dialogue
avec nos frères
quel qu'il soit tout en sachant que
problème les plus importants qu'il faut
absolument résoudre
c'est ce problème du 4 par rapport à la
libye et de vous content de la présence
et de l'action de l'armée française au
tchad
nous avons été agressés des forces
étrangères à vous renvoyer notre pays et
nous avons fait appel à nos amis
traditionnels et en particulier la
france qui a envoyé ses forces au cab et
je dois dire que les forces françaises
aux quatre sont venus pour arrêter ce
rouleau compresseur qui vient du nord
qui non seulement ne vise pas le 4 mai
qui met en cause la paix la stabilité en
afrique en général donc les forces
françaises sont venues pour arrêter
cette invasion et pour contribuer à la
paix donc de ce point de vue il y a lieu
d'attaché toute l'importance de la
présence française au calme
monsieur le président je vous remercie
venons en maintenant à l'actualité
économique et sociale en france d'abord
l'état du franc qui a manifesté
aujourd'hui de nouveaux signes de
faiblesse surtout vis-à-vis du mark
allemand qu'à côté 3 francs 0,5
aujourd'hui à paris le dollar en baisse
est repassé en dessous des 8 francs
comme tous les mois en fonction du
système de calcul des prix les prix des
carburants vont être modifiés le 12
octobre prochain un centime de moins
pour le litre de super un centime de
plus pour le litre d'ordinaire 3
centimes pour le gazole 3,4 centimes
pour le fioul domestique après leur
manifestation très couru lundi dernier à
paris les cadres de province ont répondu
aujourd'hui
ici à nantes à l'appel de la
confédération générale des cadres des
manifestations contre la politique du
gouvernement ont eu lieu dans de
nombreuses villes de province
au delà des cadres les français dans
leur ensemble perçoivent de plus en plus
mal la politique du gouvernement si on
en croit le sondage que publiera demain
vsd 44% des personnes interrogées se
disent sans illusion 16% sont révoltés
12% à mr 14 % approuvent la politique
les gouvernements dépôt de bilan à
dunlop france la direction l'annoncé
aujourd'hui au comité central
d'entreprise la cgt qui divulgue
l'information affirme que la direction
n'a donné aucune précision quant à
l'avenir de l'entreprise
la direction doit s'exprimer demain en
tout cas ce n'est pas une surprise
martine gilson 5500 salariés dont 4000
fabrique uniquement des pneus dunlop
france va mal depuis longtemps la faute
entre autres à la crise automobile
résultat fin 82 le déficit s'élève à
plus de 200 millions de francs l'accord
conclu en septembre dernier entre le
groupe d'un lob europe et le groupe
japonais sumitomo n'arrange rien et
japonais ne veulent pas des pneus
français dunlop france est alors
complètement isolé la fabrication et la
vente de balle de tennis qui elle marche
bien
n'y feront rien si la direction confirme
demain le dépôt de bilan
un syndic sera nommé mais la cgt en
appelle dès ce soir à l'état elle
demande au ministre de l'industrie de
convoquer très vite une réunion
tripartite entre les pouvoirs publics
les représentants du personnel et les
principaux fabricants de pneus le 28 ou
1982 il ya un peu plus d'un an un
communiqué officiel de l'elysée annoncé
que de dangereux terroristes avaient été
interpellés à vincennes aujourd'hui la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de paris a annulé toute la procédure qui
visait les trois irlandais arrêté à
l'époque par les super gendarme du gign
les pilotes juridique qui d'une affaire
bien embarrassante pour le gign
une de plus paul lefèvre cet arrêt de la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de paris a été prononcée sur proposition
du parquet général de la même cour parce
que les droits élémentaires de la
défense n'ont pas été respectés les
trois suspects n'étaient pas présents à
la perquisition chez eux ce qui a permis
à certains d'y placer des preuves pour
mieux les trouver première observation
les plus hauts magistrats de paris
qu'ils soient du parquet c'est-à-dire
statutairement lié au ministre la
justice ou du siège c'est-à-dire
statutairement indépendants dans leur
jugement ont rejeté donc condamné les
agissements d'un autre corps
institutionnel la gendarmerie ça veut
dire en clair que dans notre état de
droit les verrous de protection de
l'individu ont fonctionné parfois c'est
vrai c'est vrai il grince il dérape
mais cette fois ils ont fonctionné et
pourtant le dossier était délicat et la
politique pointer son nez
deuxième observation à vouloir trop
prouver on n'a rien démontré et les
trois militants irlandais qualifié
tellement vite de super terroristes
peuvent continuer de narguer la police
britannique qui d'ailleurs a dit qu'il
était trop petit pour elle troisième
observation la dernière et pardonnez moi
l'expression c'est une casserole de plus
pour le capitaine paul barril qui a
supervisé l'arrestation et la
perquisition il faudra bien qu'un jour
c'est officiers d'élite hier porté aux
nues souvenez vous en aujourd'hui
rejetés aux oubliettes muette puisse se
défendre même coupable si tenté qu'il le
soit il arrive un moment où le les
rumeurs comme on disait autrefois venise
pèsent leur poids de plomb des
précisions officielles sur le statut
actuel du capitaine barril il a été
suspendu le 9 juin dernier de toutes
fonctions d'officier de police
judiciaire
il a été affecté le 16 septembre au
commandement des écoles de gendarmerie
le ministre de la défense charles hernu
a annoncé ce soir qu'il a demandé un
rapport à l'inspection générale de la
gendarmerie à la suite des informations
parues dans la presse au sujet des
contacts que le capitaine barnils
aurais-tu avec différentes organisations
10 août
tout l'après midi
si vous avez regardé les programmes
d'antenne 2 vous avez eu droit à toutes
sortes de jeux et de démonstration qui
vous ont révélé les trouvailles et les
merveilles de la vidéo à l'occasion du
vide comme le salon professionnel des
industries de la communication qui se
tient à cannes
georges leclercq revient maintenant sur
un marché en pleine explosion
celui des jeux vidéo qui ne vise pas que
les enfants
ils sont arrivés en force dans les cafés
et dans les lieux publics qu'ils ont
détrôné les bons vieux billard baby foot
et autres flipper il
les voici ce sont les jeux vidéo ils
deviennent si nombreux que c'est devenu
une activité économique majeur à la fois
dans le domaine des loisirs et dans le
domaine de l'électronique et avec
l'irruption cette fois ci à la maison
ces jeux vidéo passe de 20000 en 1980 à
plus de 500 milles cette année du coup
c'est un marché énorme qui s'ouvre
devant les industriels et les salons
comme le mit gide à cannes lors de
vienne consacrée mais déjà après deux
ans de carrière le jeu vidéo connaît des
jours sombres
la fantastique croissance s'effondre aux
états unis par exemple de très grosses
compagnies comme atari ou mattel
subissent des pertes financières énormes
se comptant en milliards de francs
cette vague va t'elle touché la france
pas forcément disent les spécialistes
qui rappelle que me gide veut dire
marché international du jeu vidéo et de
l'informatique individuelle et
domestiques et il compte beaucoup sur le
micro ordinateur pour sauver cette
industrie
chacun d'entre nous aurons un micro
ordinateur chez lui avant la fin de la
décennie pour s'initier à cette micro
informatique le prochain à penser à
paris depuis 1976 d'apprendre les
montois informatique par le jeu et c'est
que moi besoin les gens sont maintenant
conscients qu'un micro ordinateur n'est
pas une bête que méchant mais simplement
une machine très simple à utiliser et
quoi de plus facile à utiliser qu'un jeu
en s'amusant
déjà l'on voit beaucoup de constructeurs
de consoles de jeux vidéo transformer
leurs engins en véritable
micro-ordinateurs et si cette tendance
se confirme dans quelques années il n'y
aura plus de simples jeux vidéo mais que
des micros voilà pourquoi antenne 2 a
choisi de plus en plus d'utiliser ces
micro ordinateurs à la fois dans ses
émissions
et aussi comme moyen d'initiation des
téléspectateurs à ce nouvel instrument
d'éducation
les professionnels de la communication
ont lancé aujourd'hui un appel au chef
de l'état pour qu'il mette fin aux
mesures fiscales répressive qui selon
eux visent les industries françaises
dans ce domaine du football ce soir dans
quelques minutes l'équipe de france
rencontrera l'espagne au parc des
princes un test important pour les
français après leur défaite le mois
dernier face au danemark les tricolores
menée par marius trésor tenteront de
s'imposer une équipe d'espagne qui vient
d'aligner sept matches consécutifs sans
défaite les résultats et des images de
cette rencontre dans notre dernier
journal nouveau record du monde de
vitesse automobile le britannique
richard novell a été chronométré à plus
de 1000 25 km heure à bord d'un engin
propulsé par un moteur à réaction
l'exploit a été accompli dans le désert
du rocher noir au nevada le précédent
record était de 1000 1 km heure et datée
de 1970 à presque coeur l'homme le plus
rapide du monde dans notre ville a
simplement déclaré
c'était extraordinaire
extraordinaire en effet les pronostics
de pirey braises pour le quarté de
demain à evry las le 12 le 13 le 6 le 4
le 16 le 2 et le 9
tout de suite les résultats du loto
las le 2 le 6 le 23 le 35 le 47 numéro
complémentaire est le 34 maintenant un
mot du temps de demain bauges et
simonetta et bien demain ressemblera
beaucoup pas aujourd'hui le soleil sera
au rendez vous mais c'est un soleil qui
a tendance à être dans les nuages ce
n'est pas grave car regardez la photo
satellite
l'anticyclone il est toujours là en fait
il s'étend des açores au nord de la
france ils redescendent vers les stades
plutôt vers la grèce d'ailleurs plus
fait là nous donne comme ton nom sur la
carte de demain du beau temps vraiment
beau temps l'après midi mais le matin le
brouillard sera donc si vous êtes en
voiture il faudra faire attention
surtout des charentes au massif central
et au jura
si vous êtes en mer la visibilité le
matin sera mauvais sur le golfe du lion
mais le baromètre est en hausse
le thermomètre descend très légèrement
minimum 18 de chréa presse maximum 26
degrés sur l'aquitaine et le
languedoc-roussillon avec une moyenne
nationale de 23 degrés demain jeudi 6
octobre le soleil se lèvera 6h58 il se
couchera 18h19 ce sera la saint bruno à
23h17 hervé claude qui vous présentera
notre dernier journal demain 12h45
daniel bilalian pour antenne de midi et
je vous retrouverai avec plaisir demain
à 20h très bonne soirée